questions or i tend to ask people to put
out for responses so you can do it in
chat
um so we want to make sure that your
your questions are answered or we can
point you
towards someone who can answer your
questions
um my name is ted ladaris
um so we're going to be talking today
about the the bioinformatics and
computational biology program
in d mice um and you can see that i've
got my
twitter handle and i've got my email so
if you have any
questions please let me know
okay so just a quick introduction so
as bill said i'm filling in for shannon
today
um but who am i so i'm an assistant
professor
within the division of bioinformatics
and computational biomedicine
um so one of my passions is definitely
education
so i am certified instructor for our
studio
so i teach use r studio and r to teach
quite a few different kind of data
science courses and workshops
and also i am a real big
fan of data science and teaching data
science skills
um so i was a co-founder of the
the regional regional r conference that
we call
cascadia r and also uh within ohsu we
have a group that
anyone can join including people out
from outside of ohsu
called biodata club where we host
workshops
and kind of social social kind of
discussions
about data and data science
um just in terms of my own research
interests
you know i'm very big on education and
active learning
i just feel like people learn more
better when they
actually ha like have to practice it
i spend a lot of time championing
champion mean
open science and reproducibility with my
own research work i do a lot of work
in interactive visualization i have
seen many different kinds of omics data
but i concentrate now on single cell
data and systems approaches to
understanding precision medicine
uh so um uh let's okay so let's kind of
give
uh let's give a background for all of
this
has anyone here heard of the fourth
paradigm
and just let me know in chat
okay we've got one person who said yes
so this is this is something that was
this is uh a concept that was kind of
thought of by jim gray at microsoft
and it's really kind of understanding
about understanding kind of
the world and and data i mean the first
the first paradigm is really kind of
descriptive
so can we even describe kind of
phenomena
in the world um second like kind of
based on these
kinds of simple observations or kind of
this theoretical level which we're kind
of thinking about
having theories about how the world
works
uh third is really kind of the
computational level
you know we're thinking about thinking
about things
um and we're kind of exploring like the
information
that we're giving but um you know
as bill kind of alluded to we're really
kind of um
and bioinformatics were really kind of
going into what's called the
the fourth paradigm which is really kind
of exploring
and understanding how the individual
parts
of the of a system including patients
patients work together any questions
about that
okay so let's let's talk about let's
talk about beta
so this is kind of a nice figure and
it's just talking about
all of the different kinds of data that
peop
that are attached to you as a p as a
patient or as a person
i mean starting with the clinical data
and these these percentages are
basically
how much how much of these these
different data types
contribute to your own personal
health so we believe that clinical data
it determines about 10 of like your
health status
um kind of moving from that um into kind
of the molecular level we've got
um genomics data genomics data really is
kind of determines
like 30 percent of your health
um but really the what's what's
interesting
and this is kind of where we're starting
starting to move
and bill alluded that we were just we're
not just
our department or our major is not just
about
omics anymore we're also looking at
things such as this
exogenous data um and so
these are things um has anyone heard of
social
economic determinants of health
yeah yeah so i mean things like
like geography zip code i mean they
contribute quite a bit to um quite a bit
to uh to our to our health
um and on the right here we have this um
we just basically kind of have the size
of the data
kind of generated in a lifetime
so i mean the clinical data is
relatively small to this
these kinds of exogenous data that we
collect
and this this exogenous data is also
includes things like fitbits
all of these kinds of sensors that we're
kind of collecting
reflecting about our individual health
so here who here has heard of systems
biology or systems medicine
okay one so
i mean part of the idea behind systems
biology and systems medicine is
understanding so you can see these are
all different kinds of sources of data
how do they um how did they contribute
to health
can we basically understand
you know someone's health state um but
not only that
um and this this has to do with kind of
these molecular
diagnostics such as genomics and
proteomics
can we actually build a model for how
the disease works within an individual
so a lot of this is kind of
understanding really what
the diagnostics are telling us and
interpreting them
and you know the key is really that we
we think about this at the individual
patient level
so every patient is unique in terms of
their genetic
contributions and so we need to
unders our understanding of the disease
needs to
end up at that level we ideally we want
to
tailor therapies based on for somebody
based on all of their data
um any questions about that
okay so let's
let's kind of zoom in for a second so
let's talk about autumn
um boyton so when she was three she was
diagnosed with
you know really kind of unfortunate
kidney cancer
bilateral wellness tumors um
so you know we we need to ask these
questions
for autumn so how will she respond to
like just what is the current standard
of clinical care
so um there are there are kind of
standards of clinical care
so you know autumn may uh may receive
chemotherapy kind of based on the
severity
but really for her what is the best
treatment plan it might not just be the
standard of care
um and and this is kind of an
unfortunate fact of life
um is that you know if if she relapses
how do we choose an another uh therapy
for her
so this is a very actually a very happy
story
um autumn is this is this is a pretty
old slide and autumn is
you know very healthy and she's doing
really well um but
we want to be able to help people like
autumn
so you know as you as you saw like the
major is
change itself from computational biology
to computational biomedicine
and really behind that is we need to
kind of embed
ourselves you know a lot of our work is
done with these kinds of functional
assays
and kind of these molecular
characterizations
of single patients
we need to integrate that into
into a patient care workflow and part of
that
and this is really kind of where
informatics comes in
is there is a lot of data but we need to
make it
understandable and manageable uh for
the people who are actually doing the
clinicians in healthcare
any questions about this
okay so as i've kind of alluded to this
idea of personalized
medicine or precision medicine you know
we really need to
think about um think about how do we
harness
the vast amount of data like including
genomic data
and understanding everyone's disease and
at a personal level i mean i think this
is a great quote
from this op-ed by lori becklin like the
knowledge generated from those trials
will die with us because there's no
comprehensive database
of metastatic breast cancer patients and
really in the big data era this void is
is criminal so i mean
part of it like you know like we we hear
about big data but we really have to
make it relevant
to each individual patient
so again antonio uh regalado
really talks about this you know the
unfolding calamity in genomics is that a
great deal of life-saving information
although
already collected is inaccessible
um so you know at a base
level you know each of us has about six
terabytes
of genetic information but
are we able to kind of make sense of
that in the context of larger patient
populations
so can we understand for example you
know if i were unfortunate to have
um you know something some sort of
cancer
you know could we understand you know
what my genetic state is compared to
other patients who have that similar
cancer and can we kind of help determine
courses of treatment based
on this so that's
kind of a long discussion of like you
know kind of
like where we're getting there so i want
to just talk a little bit about
the program so this is what i was
talking about before the idea of
basically humanity interaction
so let's talk more about the program so
these are all areas of study that we
have
within our division we do my
my own work i do a lot of work in
analytics and data science
many of our faculty do use
utilize machine learning approaches
and systems systems biology
this idea of understanding kind of what
is the patient state of a system
based on kind of molecular
characterizations and assays
and understanding you know where that
system
or that system may progress um these are
all kind of areas of study
um so uh yeah and if there's any
questions about these kinds of areas of
study please let me know and chat
but we are moving towards areas such as
computational neuroscience
coffee and you know like i said
computational biomedicine
is very much you know work that we are
all working on
so just to give you context you know if
you're entering our program
whether you are a phd or a master's
student
um so this is kind of what your first
year would look like if you decided to
be
a pcb student so
really um you know if for phd students
you would do basically to kind of
prepare yourself
you would do my free online our boot
camp
or i have an alternative course called
ready for r which is also free
you'd also do research rotations but
the bulk of your first year would really
be spending
spending doing coursework so it's going
to be
in basically kind of statistics
understanding understanding algorithms
how do we search
for like genetic sequences for example
or how do we kind of group patients um
on molecular characteristics using
things like clustering algorithms
um and building predictive models um
that kind of all leads uh there's also
we we do focus on computational skills
we have a scripting course
um we have a and that does a lot of work
in python we have our large scale
data databases course in which we talk
about these like kind of
uh large being able to build and query
large databases
um we're also kind of moving that into
um into like distributed computing
so we do um do some work uh with
distributed computing so you can kind of
work with that and
um and cloud computing
um and then so there is um
this kind of culminates in spring with
like the research methods
um course in which you're doing kind of
a short
achievable project on your spring
quarter
and then um depending on your
depending on your if you're a master
student with thesis
or without thesis um if you are with
thesis
you may spend your time planning for um
you know your thesis but uh the the
non-thesis
options you're going to be planning to
do internships
so the thesis is about a year-long
process
of producing kind of research on uh
independent research um with a mentor
uh the summer internship is much more
focused
on kind of practical matters and
we try um the students basically
sign up for internships with various
kinds of bioinformatics groups
um uh we've got um
i can't remember so there is i think
it's odp omex
or there is a a a group in town called
omix i believe it's omex data automation
or do
um and a lot of our students have done
internships with them but the
the real point of that is that you come
out with kind of solid skills
and that you're kind of positioned
yourself
for for a career
um if you want more information about
the courses um there is a link
and this will be sent out to you so you
can kind of
take a look at it any questions about
coursework
that what it covers and what it doesn't
cover
um how much is this first year
coursework
adapted for people who already have
degrees and say formal mathematics
or computer science and have done a lot
of research in those areas yeah
so i mean it uh it depends um
based on like what your past background
is so
we may wait um and it
this also depends on what kind whether
you're kind of phd or masters
we may waive that requirement
but we may ask um and hopefully i'm not
exactly sure
what the procedure right now is we may
you may not have to take that course
but you may have to take uh do some sort
of course
related computational course and
something that you want to do
so we do take that into consideration
um but also um this is
this is kind of it's kind of a tricky
process as well because
you know we have to understand the court
your past coursework
does that answer your question yep
okay any other questions
about coursework
so let's just talk about where our
students have ended up
i mean there are kind of um
you can end up kind of doing uh in lots
of different kind of areas
including industry um academia
um doing work for the government we have
a number of students who work for
done work for the va for example there
are also kind of private
private firms those are there are many
kind of opportunities kind of attached
to it
so just in terms we just want to give
you an idea of kind of where our
students
end up
so there is a question about bcb and the
biomedical engineering graduate program
so what i will say is that we tend to be
a little more prescribed
than the graduate the bme graduate
program
um they take a lot of our courses
actually
so um the students i would say that
that that that um
you know kind of it is very much an
engineering focus
but we do have we have had multiple
students who've come in through that
program
so i mean it's worth looking at that
program to
understand whether this this one or if
that one was kind of right for you
in terms of phds um obviously going on
to
post doc fellowships um
uh faculty positions are possible but
just to be realistic you know 75 percent
of post docs do not end up in academia
so like you know there are a lot of
other kind of areas
um that you can kind of move into like
within industry
you know if you want to work for like a
pharmaceutical
company um you can do senior analysts or
kind of staff scientists positions
um so these salaries um
like are a little inflated um so
these are the i just want to say that
these are
the salaries that come from california
as specifically the bay area so they're
kind of inflated
um but you know there are these are kind
of some of the positions that like our
students kind of
end up in um they might not have ended
up
in these systems but these are just kind
of current
listings so like for example you know
uh working for some some place like
genentech you know this is kind of their
this is kind of their base salary but i
mean it also depends
on you know what your background is
because
this this degree is useful but kind of
if you
like for example if you're a clinician
and you kind of um wanted to go out
you know you because you're you're like
the kind of work that's kind of possible
for you
is going to be different
um so uh like there's going to be some
time kind of at the end
of the session uh not this session but
um
after after um you have uh after this
to talk about salaries um salaries and
positions with virginia lanky's so if
you have
a chance please ask questions for for
so just want to end with some career
advice
so one of the great things about
bioinformatics is that i'm always
learning something new
i've had to adopt the attitude of being
a lifelong learner
but to do that you have to have a group
um
that you are willing to work with none
of us learns well alone
um some of us can do that but the
majority of us
you know you need to be able to find a
group that you can kind of discuss
all of these issues with and like you
know help each other
the coursework here is valuable we
really try to
focus on kind of direct directly
marketable skills um i will say
you know the the one thing that kind of
differentiates
us from engine uh biomedical engineering
is that we really focus
on knowledge and making data
kind of useful and interpreting
data to the point in which like you know
um
a healthcare professional can understand
it
uh so be inquisitive ask questions
um don't be afraid don't be afraid of
learning things new so um nate silver
has this great kind of metaphor
uh i don't know if it originated with
him but he talks about
foxes versus hedgehogs and hedgehogs
just kind of learn one thing and their
world is kind of constrained to that
whereas foxes have a very kind of
diverse knowledge base
and they can kind of come in and work on
different
problems um so
you know definitely look out for
research and volunteer opportunities
so like these are good ways to kind of
test drive whether this career is for
you
um and finally really your your path
is really your own and you have to kind
of discover what you're good at what
you're passionate about
and what you can do for the long term
so just want to end this with um so
we're just about out of time
uh these are talking about you know
there are some
uh d might we do do some demise seminars
um some of you may have kind of uh
experienced our seminar
um and these are the information for our
pro
um our major and kind of how you can
kind of find out more
information um this is kind of my last
slide
so i'm just kind of i am very passionate
about offering data science for free
uh learning for free um so these are
kind of two
resources that i provide for free so the
r boot camp
this is kind of an interactive course
this is completely free you just go to
the websites
you can also sign up for my ready for
our course which is more of a kind of
prescribed course but we do lots of
learning in our studio
notebooks and so you can apply for
register
you can register for free at this
mailing address
um i wish i had
made more time for questions um but
i think we are at time
we are at time um the link to the
going back to the session is up there um
and just
remember that there is still the student
panel at 2 15 so you'll be able to ask
um other bcb students about their
experiences so
thank you very much this was very
helpful okay
everybody